le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
le tableau de la france brossé par
amnesty international et sa secrétaire
général n'a rien de flatteur
les manquements aux droits de l'homme
pointé dans le rapport de l' ong parvus
ce mercredi sont nombreux à commencer
par le recours excessif à la force
amnesty international évoque par exemple
la mort de cédric joue via en janvier
2020 le maintien de l'emploi de la
technique de l'étranglement ainsi que le
port d'armes dangereuses ou encore le
peu d'entrain affiché par la france à
poursuivre les auteurs de violences
policières
il n'y avait toujours pas de mécanisme
indépendant chargé d'enquêter sur les
cas d'utilisation illégale de la force
très peu de membres des forces de
l'ordre ont fait l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires à la suite des allégations
d'usagé excessif de la force
pendant les manifestations de 2018 et
2019 des violences policières toujours
impunis et que la loi de sécurité
globale rendrait encore plus compliqué à
sanctionner si on en croit la patronne
d'amnesty international la loi de
sécurité globale à renforcer le pouvoir
des forces de l'ordre à imposer une
forme de surveillance a contraint les
témoins les citoyens à être beaucoup
plus sur leurs gardes
quand ils ont quand ils sont les témoins
de violences policières plus
généralement le rapport note un recul de
certaines libertés liberté de se réunir
avec une interdiction générale de
manifester imposée temporairement par le
gouvernement en mai dernier recul de la
liberté d'expression également avec la
poursuite de nombreuses personnes pour
outrage à agents ou apologie du
terrorisme des infractions jugées trop
vague par les ong mais amnesty
s'inquiète surtout en ces temps de
covile d'un recul de l'état de droit
avec les mesures d'exception imposer un
peu partout à travers la planète et
notamment en france
ce que le coc vide a permis c'est une
normalisation des mesures d'urgence ou
en d état d'urgence donc les phénomènes
de surveillance les pouvoirs accrus à la
police la grande frayeur la grande
inquiétude d'amnesty
finale c'est de voir ce projet ce que
nous avons déjà vu au nom du contre
terrorisme c'est à dire la normalisation
des mesures exceptionnelles et amnesty
n'est pas la seule à s'inquiéter de ces
dérives même des députés de la majorité
ont tenu en février dernier a alerté le
premier ministre sur je cite l'extension
quasi illimitée des prérogatives de la
puissance publique et la réduction
drastique des libertés fondamentales
outre les reculs de ses libertés on peut
aussi relever dans ce rapport la vente
d'armes irresponsable notamment révélé
par le média d'investigation disclose en
2019 le gouvernement a continué de
vendre des armes à l'arabie saoudite et
aux émirats arabes unis malgré la forte
probabilité qu'elle soit utilisée pour
commettre des violations des droits
humains dans le cadre du conflit au
yémen
nous vendons des armes à des états qui
sont reconnus comme responsables de
crimes de guerre de crimes contre
l'humanité et cetera
et pour clore cet éloge on peut enfin
citer en vrac le non-respect du droit
d'asile et des droits des migrants
le manque de moyens déployés par l'état
face à l'urgence climatique le racisme
de certains membres des forces de
l'ordre ou les grandes entreprises
françaises qui sont encore trop
nombreuses à ne pas se soucier du
respect des droits humains par leurs
sous traitants
n'en jetez plus la coupe est pleine et
donc face à tous ces manquements la
secrétaire générale d'amnesty
international tire la sonnette d'alarmé
quand on s'engage dans une politique qui
remet en cause ses droits nous nous
engageons dans une politique la france
s'engage dans une politique extrêmement
nocive pour l'ensemble des droits
humains un comble pour la patrie
supposées des droits de l'homme 1